I've flown past Mach 1 several times off
the carrier the most exciting portion of
it is getting shot off the front end
your body is experiencing this different
feel to it completely from the euro 250
miles an hour in about two and a half
seconds
I'm Tim Hibbert's I am a pilot and I
have flown faster than the speed of
sound when you're sitting on the carrier
at night you're right across from the
island which has all these big orange
sodium lights it's this orange glow
that's hauling everything and
everybody's almost monochromatic and
outside of that is just pitch black as
soon as they punch the button and you
start off on the catapult we've got
these lights now that were around you
and now they're streaking past you your
body is pulled back into the seats your
hearing is now assaulted you're under
these extreme forces anything that could
go wrong now could be really disastrous
in the next few seconds
suddenly reach the end of the catapult
and all you're left with is hanging out
for an instant you can feel here and see
nothing totally different experience for
the person who's watching it from
outside so you're watching this airplane
and he's raging by you but you still
can't hear a thing
and then he'll get four or five hundred
feet past you and then suddenly thunder
hit you and it just rattles everything
and it just compresses your chest it's a
little wonky for for a half a second you
just take this really quick snapshot
okay did I die
I don't think I died okay everything is
cool again yeah everything is cool again
and then you you continue with your
mission